alright let's talk about some more
first-person games we've no shortage of
first-person video games first-person
military games have been around for
donkey's years and this year we got two
very colorful of first-person games in
fact one of them is out already got
seven to ten on gamespot another one's
at in a couple of weeks march towards i
March May twenty-fourth two weeks from
now I believe and I think you're
reviewing that one are you correcting
all right so you're being overwatch
battleborn is already out and the beta
for overwatch closed earlier today
battleborn is still alive and kicking
bunch of people playing it online at the
moment and but one of the sort of weird
questions we keep getting even though
people about access to to both games now
in some sort of form it's like what's
the fundamental difference between these
two games and I think that was a big
problem years ago when we had battle
born and battle cry and blood-borne all
coming out of the same time like that
name got confusing yeah and and then
overwatch obviously came and people were
like oh it's another first-person mobile
what's going on what's going on what's
going on so we said we do a short video
sort of just explaining what the two
games are because they are actually very
very different I'm Erin first of all
you've played a lot of battle born over
the past couple of weeks and if you'd
explain like in a nutshell like elevator
pitch style what is battleborn
battleborn is a the best way to describe
is it's a knot Borderlands equal okay
it's it's not Borderlands but it has the
same feel of borderlands the same sort
of status effects and shooting and like
weightlessness you take the shooting
formula from Borderlands you instead of
unlocking guns you're unlocking people
who have abilities and it has an
extensive single-player campaign as well
as the sort of MOBA asked multiplayer
and and you're playing both just to get
your characters unlocked and your are
you primarily playing with other people
then like sort of borderlands you could
go either way I played solo most of the
time but most people seem to enjoy
pairing off what's been your experience
with in terms of Paula format that you
have to play with other people oh yeah
and you can do the campaign by yourself
but it's not recommended a lot of the
challenges you'll find very difficult
particularly if you pick a support class
character and it's just more fun with
friends it's one of those game
where I think your friends are the best
part of it right and the characters
themselves I'd like I got to say they
put a lot of love into the characters of
battle born they really like they're
hilarious they say really funny stuff
while you're fighting with them they
feel like they all have back stories and
personality and they react to the
environment differently and even a
multiplayer they will call things out
that surprised me like hey there's that
sniper guy again or like so you're
supposed to run away from the bullets
like one of the guys I died real quickly
and he's like so this is our first match
alright you know they like their
personality shine through and I think
that's my favorite part of the game cool
on the other side of us Mike a bunch of
us have been playing over watching in
the office at the moment and sort of
taking that as your starting point that
this is a sort of a very team-based team
co-op sort of experience in the vein of
a you know floaty weightless not battle
plan give me the word gimme two words
Portland Ore lions game thank you and
what is what would you explain overwatch
to somebody who sort of already knows
what battleborn is sure so overwatch is
more of a class-based multiplayer
shooter competitive it I know like a lot
of people thought it might be more of a
mobile when I first came out because
there is a incursion mode in battle for
battle born is very much mobile their
minions and you're taking you're
destroying these towers or your Stern
these robots are essentially like the
the towers and whatnot before you get to
the fortress overwatch is more of a no
like it says if you took team fortress
which had nine classes I think and just
put made 21 different classes and made
them all crazy and really in-depth
characters it's more there it borrows
from like shooters styles from different
shooter games right so you have diva
who's got this tank she can get into
it's like titanfall then you have Farah
the airborne Rocketeer who's kind of
like a quake character it's very much
like taking the best of different
shooter genre and pitting them against
each other in this more fast very fast
pace the objectives are there but
they're almost more to facilitate to
just the fighting between these really
crazy characters right so battleborn
sort of has more all-encompassing
scenarios in terms of like objectives
right you've got your single-player
single-player modes
they have like relatively medium Lee
compacts and objectives and in the
multiplayer sort of has a lot of wheels
sort of spinning at the same time yeah
the single-player also has a story which
is pretty big difference from overwatch
which is just purely a shoot of
multiplayer competitive shooter so I
mean probably the biggest difference in
the two is just that battleborn does
have a story mode I can't run exactly
how long it is but it's pretty meaty
each mission is about can be up to like
30 to 40 minutes depending on how you
play them oh is I think it like so like
a standard online game as well in in
battle born would that be around that
time as well you're talking like they're
a little bit length almost there a
little bit longer than I expected
actually the multiplayer matches they
can I don't know it depends what you
like and people who like that John will
probably enjoy it I found that they ran
a little bit longer than I wanted but
also there's a lot to do other than just
kill other people there's there's the
whole upgrade tree that you go through
every match a lot of that has to do with
you farming minions and preventing
minions and certain modes like I think
incursion from there the things that
actually win the match so it's got its
got some really fun aspects that don't
involve you just fighting other people
like you can bait other people away from
the minions so that you get the points
or you can suicide into a pack of enemy
minions doesn't matter if you die your
Katie doesn't matter what matters that
you stop the minions and I like the fact
that it's not just purely focused on
Katie and killing other players there's
actually there's actual strategy to it
and in that regard it's it's it's a lot
of fun actually so they you're saying
like lengths of the the maps there
around the sort of 40 minute mark and
then you also have this in level or in
mission leveling system where you were
sort of dinging your character their
level 4 and then you open up this skill
tree again sort of like a MOBA in terms
of either leveling or in terms of you
know acquiring new abilities you know
via a shop or via you know upgrading
yourself because of the level and on the
other side of a mic that stuff doesn't
exist in overwatch right the matches are
much shorter right yeah the matches i
think the quickest i've done is probably
i mean if you're playing on a good team
against a bad team it can be like four
minutes five minutes but the longest
i've seen is probably just above 15 if
that you should be 10 min america right
because 15 is pretty long and it's all
you know you get the
attack and defend objectives where you
taking point a and then defense kind of
falling back to defend point B and then
the attackers win if you do that then
you're escorting these payloads which
kind of you know there are classes kind
of their the tank characters a function
better to absorb damage and kind of push
an objective offensive characters
defensive characters support like
healers and she'll ders but yeah they're
not each match within each match there
static aside from gaining a tall and
kind of using that which their most
powerful attack belaboring you're
actually using that helix system to gain
new abilities as you go and you have the
loadout system with the items which is a
very mobile thing to its streamlined at
battleborn but in overwatch you just
that your character and their abilities
abilities go yeah well maybe you know
some of them have got more office which
which sounds it's deceivingly simple
deceivingly it seems simple but it's
becomes complex and how different
characters interact with each other how
different characters can buff each other
or counter each other if you're on the
other team how different characters can
play both offense and defense it's very
it becomes very nuanced the more you
play and play I don't even know how many
hours I've played now with the beta and
the early access but at this point I'm
still playing new characters I like
barely touch before and it's it's kind
of forcing you to realize how all these
layers interact and it's yeah it's it's
fun game cool Alyssa sort of a top level
/ look at those two games over watching
battleborn obviously so much of what you
enjoy from a first-person shooter comes
from just how it feels and then and and
how accustomed you are to that in terms
of the sort of first-person games you
usually play and iron yourself which one
is sort of feels better for you which
one of you enjoying the most set up to
it's funny but I'm actually starting to
trend towards ever watch this is a
cleaner experience battleborn as much as
I love the characters I've had a couple
of rounds of where to when especially I
was a melee character it devolved into
waiting into large groups of people
smashing the attack button with the
screen being so full of status effects
in like just people's bodies and like
random butts flying by that like the
only thing you can tell is if you are in
the scrum or out of the scrum right and
other than that you're just staring at
your meters and and and mashing the
attack button whereas overwatch in many
ways seems to be just a more cleanly
focused title hmm um but again if you're
a single-player person and you
like the characters and you like the
personality of the characters then I
think battleborn is more your style what
about yourself like I prefer overwatch
at this point for sure i'll be playing
battle born in the weeks leading up to
over watches launched an official launch
and 24th but yeah overwatch is just kind
of scratching that itch for these
characters are easy to learn really easy
to learn each one of them even if you
don't like once you grab the controls
you'll be able to figure it out there
the UI is pretty good but like still I'm
still mastering some of my main
characters or trying to I don't know
mastering so right where that's selling
myself too high but uh yeah overwatch is
the one that's I'd I'm thinking might be
one of my like go to games throughout
the year right yeah yeah I kind of feel
the same way I actually sort of feel a
little bit sorry for when battleborn has
come out I feel like this was a game I
wish came out back in January or
something that wasn't that much to play
because I did I enjoyed him more than I
thought I would cuz I'm probably not the
best person to try and sell battleborn
to because I wasn't a massive fan of
borderlands and for whatever reason the
way that came shoot the shooting works
with the you know numbers popping off
and stuff Tommy senator reason I never
got really that much into the division
either or destiny to that effect so I
don't think I'm exactly the person they
should be marketing I came towards
anyway but I did actually really enjoy
his tinkering mode that's the what is
called right and in battle born I
thought that that was a unique sort of
that wasn't enjoy the way of doing that
that was enough happening on screen
where wasn't like the single-player
stuff where it was super crazy and there
it almost felt like objective list
because it was so much going on and
where is it felt more easy to control
than something like Paragon which I
played a little bit the week previous
which something about the camera didn't
feel right in terms of like trying to do
these ranged and AOE attacks I thought
battleborn did a way better version of
that and but yeah it's kind of a weird
little crisis they have where where
they're coming out alongside something
which although very very different and
obviously doesn't have some of the stuff
you're talking about single player and
some of the core functionality of that
game or at least just in terms of it
being a first-person game you play on
the internet it seems like overwatch and
Blizzard are sort of doing their own
throwing thing is that randy pitchford
on the phone yeah you just have any say
I'm up shut up or do I just tell till
they stop well we also have lawbreakers
on the horizon 20 you you're right i
wish i was surprisingly i was surprised
with I I had a good time at PAX East his
lawbreakers basically another over
no it's more like well yes it's okay so
it's closer over Watson is battle born
but it's like unreal mix with quake okay
which the translocator with a railgun
exactly got it yeah can't wait for that
video lawbreakers what is lawbreakers
yeah we'll do that one next I guess
thank you so much both of you for coming
in so early as you actually obey the law
the entire play that game it's like a
battlefield hardline it's just like show
the show the shield you drive at the
speed limit and you professionally greet
other players in the middle of the
massive the cop yeah looking forward to
that one ah yeah thank you so much for
coming in talking about over watching
battleborn i let us know in the comments
if you played either or both if you got
involved in the overwatch open beta what
did you think of that and have you been
enjoying battleborn I mean all right in
there for a couple of weeks now so it's
the perfect time to go and pick that one
off the baby give it a go let us know
your thoughts in the comments below
Oh